welcome back to New rockstars and
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania is a
movie of many rings the Rings King made
outside of his base of operations and
the boxing ring he made inside of his
base of operations when he stopped on
Scotland's face repeatedly it was great
but also quite sad but what if I told
you that the most important rings of all
is the movie's connection to the
tannerings from chongqi this is Rogue
Theory the show where we pitch the
wildest theories for the nerdy titles
that we love my name is Mt and going
wrong with me today is the Quantum to my
mania it's Jessica Clemens what's going
on Jessica no that was sweet that was
cute thank you
that was cute no problem I'm the cutest
man in the world just kidding and it's
the only person who I drink mysterious
alien goo with on a Saturday night it's
Whitney van laningham what's going on
with me oh hell yeah baby let's play
ooze pong next time let's destroy
everyone at ooze Pond
oh my God that would be so much fun for
those of you who may not have seen on
Twitter the last time Mt was in town he
and I dominated and crushed everyone in
the office at ping pong or ping pong
beer pong and it was incredible and I
think that we should make it the winning
shot and it was something out of a movie
it was amazing I was like wow this is
incredible it's so fun we're all drunk
up a white cloth I'm just kidding
and we picked him up from the quantum
realm ourselves our lovely friend DJ
Woodridge what's going on my friend
thank you for saving me from the quantum
realm
okay was like yo this book that DJ wrote
is amazing I need to keep him here he's
not going anywhere please tell everyone
about your hellbent comic DJ because oh
my goodness please and thank you yes go
over to hellbentcomicbook.com uh there's
probably a link in the description or
you could just go to hellbent
comicbook.com or you could go to
Kickstarter that's where the book is and
type in hellbent three and that should
take you to the third and final volume
of my comic series hellbent it's a
supernatural Thriller in the vein of
like if you're a fan of something that's
killing the children or preacher or
Sandman hellbent is the comic for you
and if you're new to Hellman I know I've
been on the show before talking about
and I know you're lovely fans have
supported it and I thank them so much
but if you have not supported it so far
fear not you can get all three volumes
in one go I think that's 136 pages of
story beginning middle and end the whole
shebang one go uh please go over there
we just uh hit our second stretch goal
we're working on our third
uh which is
um some nice uh updated cover stock uh
trying to where's the point now we're
trying to make this comic as good get
you as good a product as possible I know
I've got volumes one and two over here
uh I know you can't feel it because
you're an internet land but if you could
feel this cover ooh baby
I can see like the way it shines in the
night and I kind of do whatever
it feels so nice and we're just trying
to get that nice sexy cover stock for
volume three as well
for good cover stock baby oh yeah so go
over to hellventcomicbook.com and go
support it please and thank you yes
please
hellbentcomicbook.com everybody thank
you oh yeah hell band let's go I love I
love dope comic books I love comic books
made
um by really fun people so it's cool
that we're like friends with someone who
made a comments bro I usually have to go
to one con to meet a Comic Book Creator
and here they are coming to me so thank
you cool thank you thank you for having
me I appreciate it but yeah this is my
first topic of the day I believe that it
is possible that Kang stole the ten
rings from a multiversal when woo
um and here's why I think this because
we all know that Kang is a Multiverse or
conqueror Who has fought and killed
Avengers before like you said like yeah
I've done the whole Avengers fighting
thing you know and whatever I kill them
all no big deal I just do this this is
my Tuesday but then when all the
Avengers die then who else is going to
defend the planet but one of the oldest
people on the planet Wen Wu The Warrior
who you know would eventually face King
and lose even though he has this amazing
alien ring technology he's not from the
future he's from the distant past and uh
he's doing some past things
um that Kang has probably seen before on
his DVDs and I believe that Kang stole
his Ring's technology to make a new
power source to Traverse the Multiverse
because as we saw
um in um King the ten rings when uh
shung chi does that weird Kamehameha
wave thingy it's the ring spin around
sort of like that machine that we saw in
our Ant-Man and the was quantumania so I
think that there's a chance here that uh
we could have seen Kang fight owenwoo
win a win from when Wu
um and then um take the Rings from
win-woo and
um yeah and use the Rings to power his
machine what do you guys think about
this when would he have done this
I'm a sucker for a good punch and like
that was a good one that's not even a
real question I have I just wanted to
say it
but I do think a compelling aspect of
that question Whitney is I am kind of
bombed that as of yet they haven't
really taken advantage of the time
travel aspect of Kang in the sense that
like there's a point I don't know about
you all when I'm sitting in an Ant-Man I
was like how did he end up in the
quantum realm and I thought it'd be so
cool if it's actually post Kang Dynasty
like the events of King Dynasty end up
sending him back into the quantum realm
and so it's a functionally a Time Loop
and then they did it's like oh no the
other king said I'm like all right
um but it'd be interesting if perhaps if
if we stick with this theory that he got
the ranks that perhaps if there we get a
Shang Chi too prior to King Dynasty if
that leads into him getting it listen
theoretically it'd be interesting in
actuality I don't know that the MCU does
the best with some of these bigger
Cosmic stuff like like uh dotting all
the eyes and Crossing all the t's so I
don't know that it will work but in
theory it'd be cool if something
happened in a later movie in the future
that informed stuff Kang did in the past
you know what I mean that would be cool
that really that would be really dope
and very satisfying yeah um and I feel
like that could potentially happen
because like we're dealing with a lot of
weird time travel stuff we're in the era
of time travel in the Multiverse and
like I feel like the MCU could set up
stuff in the past that could pay off in
the future in some weird like time thing
I I I'm a big fan of um I don't know if
you guys watched Doctor Who oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah like the whole River Song
aspect I sadly don't but my brother is
obsessed with it and so I know most
things about it but I I haven't gotten
into it and at this point I'm like
there's so much where would I start uh
uh actually I think a great place
anytime there's a new doctor great time
to start I uh suggest to people the 11th
Hour which was the Matt Smith's first
one it's such a good like hey here's yes
basically everything you need to know in
one episode and it's just a great uh
intro into the whole thing Matt Smith is
the best but the eighth is my favorite
the eight is your favorite doctor but
yeah I don't know why I think it's
because that's where I started when I
was young and I was sexually attracted
to him
um but Matt Smith was a really good that
was honestly probably my favorite
version of Doctor Who was just eight was
where I started yeah and I like Capaldi
a lot because I love me an old cranky
doctor but yeah oh my God was my
favorite doctor and then Capaldi came
and like freaking stole my like my
entire soul like you are the doctor but
yeah that's kind of what made me think
about this is Moffitt loved doing that
like seating like uh the whole River
Song like their first meeting is
actually their last meeting that stuff I
love doing like I love stuff like that
and I feel like you know uh like we saw
a piece of that I mean guardians of
galaxy Vol 2 with the abolis because we
we saw when we first meet the the
tentacle monster in Guardians 2 it has a
cut on its neck I think he's gonna get
that cut in Guardians three and some
time travel Shenanigans but I'm putting
a rogue Theory inside of another Rogue
Theory
I'm honestly that's that's honestly a
video I'm going to be working on
sometime in the future
um but yes
um but yeah I feel like the MCU has that
type of mindset and I would love to see
um some some like weird time thing where
like it set up something in the past in
the events of the movie but like yeah I
I would love stuff like that but yo no
what do you ladies think about this
theory of um the when was Rings being
adapted into this technology I really
like it I guess my problem with it which
is not a problem it's that which could
potentially be true after seeing Ant-Man
and wasp pontomania
I guess I'm like why would king the
Conqueror come to a different timeline
and Destroy This human
so it's like why show up to this planet
Earth when you have access to every
timeline every Universe every planet
items seems kind of crazy listen that
was thanos's whole back he just went
planted the planet and beat up people
for their gems but he needed the Rings
to do the actual act where when where
King doesn't need these rings to do
anything unless he was originally the
person that created the Rings and they
got lost and went to Winwood and that
makes sense he's getting them back but
I'm like I feel like you could get the
equivalent of these Rings somewhere else
on a different plan but I I get but I I
I I think it is I think you're true I
just I'm wondering why when will keep
going sorry no no no no I like this
question it's a very good question and I
and I think this um Harkens back to you
I was actually reading
um King's origin comic I forget which
comic it was and um it basically was
like yeah Kang really was obsessed with
like he was bored with living in this
futuristic society and he was obsessed
with like looking at the figures of the
past and I think that on one of those
past figures that he could have been
obsessed with
um meeting is um like this dude has been
like a major figure in um a human
history for such a long time and there's
probably even timelines where like he
lived um he didn't die at the event of
shangchi and like he just lived for a
very long time and like maybe like he's
just a very old person
um but yeah I think that maybe Xiang Chi
is like hey this is um this iconic
figure he has this iconic 10 rings and
like maybe these second ten Rings could
be used to
um amp up my technology because he's all
about like learning more about um upping
his technology game as we learned from
um when he met all the kings and they
learned from each other so I don't know
I feel like it could happen but it is
weird to be like yeah I'm for the future
let's go to this I'll get this old ass
technology for this old man or just yeah
let's jump this old man his Rings okay
but like here's here's how that could
happen right he could have a similar
thing that happened in quantumania where
maybe he came to Earth and he got stuck
or something or like he was stuck
somewhere and he needs the 10 rings to
fuel something to get back home and like
that's the closest technology to what he
needs first I like that I really like
that you know because like Kane doesn't
get stranded from time to time like Mr
Griffin is a perfect example
um the Mr Griffin bearing of Kang he's
like I'm stuck here might as well become
a businessman and um mess with people's
lives
um to try to get out and so yeah I can
see him like being stuck at some point
during when was rain and just being like
you know what I'll take those because
that's the highest piece of technology I
could find right now yeah because even
if it yeah like even if it's technically
like like shittier older technology than
what he's used to it could be like the
closest thing to what he needs and then
that's why he's getting him that's
that's
where I'm going to give you like a bonus
rogus
um for me for my imaginary pocket in my
sweater sweater that has no pockets
um I'm here it has a big pocket
underneath so yeah I guess I guess we
just vote on this like what do you guys
theory of of
um Kang potentially stealing these rings
from Wen Wu at some point in human
history and just adapting them and
carving these weird symbols on them and
just saying yeah this is mine it wasn't
when loses mine totally my technology
I'm so smart
Mr rogus because Marvel villains Love
jewelry baby they all love it
the 10 Rings King could be into the
bracelet aspect of it let's let's just
yeah let's just give the villains their
jewelry we're gonna have jewelry forever
like we got the quantum bands uh we got
like yeah it's all jewelry
um I would love to see I would love if
they said that like all this jewelry
belonged to one person it's like I've
been dripped out at all times
I was like oh it's my stuff yeah what do
you think DJ do you think this theory is
Rogue is bogus or ogus I'm gonna say I'm
sorry I feel I don't want to be a
Negative Nancy but I do I do speaking
truth I'm gonna say What's your opinion
I'm gonna say bogus just because for
this thing to work it would require them
to already know the origin of the Rings
and I don't think I I got the strong
impression chongqi was like well we're
just gonna kick this can down the road
until we can figure out where these
Rings came from uh so yeah yeah we just
require a little bit of a future
planning that it's not which is not the
uh the impression I've gotten from the
most recent movies okay yeah all right
no that's fair all right so what rogus
one one bogus what do you think Jessica
um I think I I'm in the middle I think
it's in August because I think I had a
theory where I also said that the Rings
came from Kang but I said that Kang
created the Rings and that's why he's
getting them back and we said these are
the Rings came from Kang yeah
people that were on the planet in the or
in the comics
he got sucked out the ring stayed on his
ship and they were able to take it
um I think there is a king that did it
I think there is a king that's dumb
enough to have done that
um
can you imagine being the dumbest of all
the kings
everyone in the break room thinks this
is the dumb King this is King the
Conqueror is the dumb king
um it's too easy for him to get trapped
and do everything yeah I remember
Brandon called him simple Kang to me
once and I thought that was great who
thinks this is the dumb one the one in
quantumania yeah
I
have amazing technology that I can move
people with my mind but I'm not gonna
use it in the final fight
okay
yeah I'm just going oh because uh yeah
okay no I will collect all of these like
Thanos in the Infinity Stones I will
collect each one a rogue is a bogus and
an August now I snap my fingers and the
depression remains just kidding all
right um but now it is okay thank you
guys be like that sometimes it'd be like
that
um but thank you guys I love all these
answers but up next Jess has an amazing
Rogue theory about quantumania
um that I cannot wait to hear but first
uh be sure to check out nerd riot.shop
where you can always grab the latest and
greatest new Rockstar's gear right now
our quantumania inspired merch is 15 off
through the end of the month that's
right we threw some pin particles at
that merch and shrunk the price they
didn't think it could be done but we uh
we got the science we made it happen so
grab it before it's lost in the quantum
realm forever also our brand new
Mandalorian inspired merch is dropping
on the channel this week like a chunk of
best car into the armorous forge and
we're bringing back shout outs for our
Mandalorian gear so when you pick up a
piece of Mandalorian inspired merch you
unlock the opportunity to get a custom
shout out that will appear on Wikileaks
our Mandalorian after so support the
channel and check out all of our great
merch options over at
nerdriot.shop and guys um if you have
always wanted to submit one of your
Rogue theories we're going to try
something new here on the show I'm going
to be your Rogue Theory lawyer if you
use the hashtag Rogue Theory and you you
submit your series I will act as your
lawyer and defend your theory before our
magnificent panel of judges and you guys
will vote on their Theory and I will try
my darndest to uh to to back them up so
yes use the hashtag hearing on Twitter
that is so cool because people DM me
theories all the time yes and I'm always
like I can't say your theory because
then I'd be stealing your theory so I'm
not gonna say it but this is like the
perfect way to get to like say all the
cool series that people message us
so I feel like a great place to talk
about them dude hell yeah this is great
tweak your theory using the hashtag
Rogue Theory um you could tweet them at
New Rock shows as well and um yeah it'll
be fun to get you guys um get you guys
theories on the show but anyway this
leads us to our second topic for today
which the lovely Jessica Clemens will
take over right now take it away Jessica
thank you from the Segway
um mine is very brainy and I didn't
write it down so we're gonna have to
walk it through it
that's exactly what I
like
so essentially I think a lot of people
think that Kang the Conqueror isn't dead
after Quantum Mania he got sucked into
the energy Corps but we don't know what
happened within or outside well we know
what happened outside the energy core
but we don't know what happened within
the energy core and I think because time
doesn't matter logic doesn't matter
nothing matters when it comes to time
place what space whatever in the MCU now
uh I think that once Kang the Conqueror
went into the energy core he is going to
stay there for God knows how long
because it's outside of time and space
and create immortices limbo and I think
he's going to become limbo and he was
sent to the quantum Realm by amortis who
is going to be the head of the king
Council just so he can make sure that
all of these things happen to his T step
by step for him to become his ultimate
self so when we see a mortise at the end
post-credits scene that's gonna be our
like that's our ultimate immortus but he
had to get King the conquer his younger
self to go into the energy core and
become limbo in the energy core once
you're in I believe this only because
I'm like once you're this happened
before in the comics with uh the Pharaoh
Rama Tut once he went into limbo he saw
every outcome to every uh variant
version of himself and he took the one
that he wanted to become so once he got
out of the energy core he became I think
the Scarlet Centurion or he might have
become a mortise himself but he was able
to see every possible outcome so once he
was sent King the Conqueror into the
energy Corps he's going to create limbo
himself and he's going to be able to see
every one of his variant outcomes and
become the full ultimate immortus which
we see at the post-credits scene
interesting
immortices the is the one with the snake
the snake
I know they seem the same two very
different characters yeah I believe I I
really want to believe believe that
limbo exists within the quantum realm
and a different version in the quantum
realm since it's outside of space and
time so why couldn't it be the inside of
the energy core itself uh and that
always existing within the quantum realm
and only Kane can enter it I really like
this idea of Kang creating um limbo or
like you know Scott creating Limbo with
his weird actions
um and Kang taking it over and like
slowly becoming immortus because like
it'd be I I like a good origin story a
secret origin story it's like oh that
was secretly me and like I'm now I'm in
charge
um yeah I I like this idea a lot thank
you I'm thinking about it and I'm like
okay so what if Kang is like a little
piece of pepperoni the core is a Hot
Pocket and then the Hot Pocket is
wrapped in the cheese which is the
Quantum realm and then you can put it on
a sandwich and that's our reality boom
I'm hungry that's how I'm choosing
part I got very confused
it was a [__] wrong delicious inside
is cold and the inside's real hot and
then yeah it's so hot so spicy I think
there's an analogy for the quantum realm
that is definitely a Hot Pocket it works
because if you put like a Hot Pocket in
a hot pot if you put a Hot Pocket in a
calzone that would be in a calzone
that's way better than what I said yes
yes this is why I [__] need you
because you are so goddamn smart yes I
feed everyone's munchie Theory we got it
we gotta get my companion back in here's
Louise and he can crack the Hot Pocket
metaphor for yeah okay oh he could crack
it better than anything you can connect
Hot Pockets to uh Quantum science it can
be done as a component of this theory is
that the Kang from this move this is not
the last we've seen of this Kang which
feels like it's supposed to be Kang
Prime technically right this is supposed
to be everyone else has a different like
a mortise he remains whatever this is
the king of kangs no I think well I
think a more is gonna be the king of
kings
um only because there's so many that we
saw once you saw that post credit scene
and they only focused on three I was
like okay how many can they get through
between now and Kang Dynasty and so I
think they're just gonna stick with
those three as being the like leader of
the actual kegs and we're never gonna
get higher than that so the three kangs
make out a tears
yeah and then the veil opens up we go
into Miss Marvel
yeah yeah yeah there it is it all
connects maybe you don't connect the
veil only opens once the Kings have sex
with each other hear me out yeah uh it
makes sense yeah yeah that definitely
happened at one point let's be real he's
a narcissist uh but anyway there's no
way there wasn't a gang bang somewhere
[Music]
if there was many Whitney's throughout
time I would [__] every version of
myself I'd be like alligator Whitney yes
lizard Whitney yes absolutely
I can really like hardcore identify with
Ant-Man because my very first job ever
was at Haagen-Dazs at the mall and I got
fired because I gave out too many free
samples I was not aware that there was a
list
um it was apparently a limit of free
samples and it was my best friend's 18th
birthday so I gave her 18 free yeah
yeah so Scott Lang and I both have this
in common that we got fired from an ice
cream place so like you were just giving
samples to too many individual people
it's like my one friend but I also did
that for like children because like if
kids were like can I try this one I'd
give them like seven because I'm not
gonna turn down like a cute little kid
who just wants ice cream like so yeah
they they were like Whitney this is the
final straw you've been giving out too
many free samples in eight Mr
Haagen-Dazs came down himself he's like
what the [__] are you doing what are you
doing
the best thing here is that it's like
Kang and limbo got all of the free
samples and then he became immortus is
what we're saying yes exactly exactly
that's how he becomes Immortal here's my
problem with that theory that tells me
that we're gonna build to the Avengers
fighting snake voice King and I don't
want that I don't want I don't want I
don't want to spend I don't want to
spend any more time with snake voice
King than we have to
we were like I don't I don't genuinely I
don't think I want to spend time with
any of them except for ramadet but they
I don't like that he had the most not
only did he have the most lines he was
the one that started the line that was
like they're coming to us we have to
defeat them first so it's like and he
stood in the front in the Triangle so I
was like damn amortis is the leader of
the council yeah I was like okay yeah I
was like okay Kane got sucked into the
coin and sucked into the core okay okay
and then they showed all the kings and I
was like Boo no thanks no thank you
mistake I'm sorry everybody wait let's
let's bet let's roll roll back on Kang a
little bit I I like this idea of this um
very raspy voice Kang being the leader
because like the sound system on that
place must be really great because like
you just be like hello everyone it's
time to what it's time
what are you saying it's time to get the
attack we can't hear you bro like I
don't know
you'll probably talk the the least
during the actual movies okay hold on
hold on how about this how about this
how about this okay we get uh oh King
Dynasty opens up immortus walks in and
then suddenly he like it's like he's
choking on something and then Kang Prime
claws his way out of a mortise like
pulls like he's been hiding inside him
he's like like I was like ah it's me the
whole time
all of being so mean to Jonathan Majors
he we worked so hard to do that stupid
voice
I personally like the voice a lot
um and I think it's supposed to hearken
back too there was one time in the um in
the Marvel Comics where um the mortis
pretended to be this um person called
the Whisperer
um and I think that's probably what he
probably took inspiration from this
Whisperer
um Persona of a mortise so I don't know
that's just a weird thought that I had
okay if if the whisper King doesn't
cover the whisper song by the Yin Yang
Twins
every time they uh arrive at a new
universe quite the Avengers like how you
doing love it
hahaha
but anyway let's put on this Theory um I
like this Theory a lot about Kang
eventually becoming a mortgage what do
you guys think do you guys think it's
rogus bogus or ogis I think that I want
to give this an ogus because like I
think that it could be possible and I
like it a lot but um I think that a king
hates a mortis so much
um especially in the comics and like
he's so vengeful at these kinds of kings
that I don't I don't think that he'd
become the man that he hates but I think
that it'd be really fun this is true
yeah this is true we all become
different people so does iron lad
technically so it's like yeah
I was thinking amazing point you know
what you got me yeah
no no no no no no no no no
I like it
got it we stick to our guns after they
draw
what do you think DJ uh you know I think
I'm gonna go with an August as well
because I like it I like it it'd be cool
but again like the similar Theory it
requires a amount of Level A level of
planning ahead
that I'm not convinced is happening so
uh I'm gonna I'm Gonna Keep it I'm gonna
keep it as August
humble thing for the MCU to hear to be
honest
that would probably be like damn that
man's right yeah that would hit him like
where yeah well because it's like it's
like uh Kang and he who remains have the
same goal it's the same but they're not
the same person anyway whatever I just I
listen I had issues I had issues with
quantumania I had issues with the movie
no you didn't you did you did they
showed that Janet had pin particles the
whole time why didn't she just Escape
anyway whatever it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter I don't
think I don't think I don't think the
internal logic of that movie holds up
sorry anyway with me what were your
thoughts
because I too can relate to hating the
man I've become and I think that that's
just entirely possible and I was also
gonna say the iron lad thing too because
like that guy became the king you know
so I I totally think this is possible
I'm I'm roguessing it I like how you
said I hate the man I've become you're
the most beautiful man I've ever seen
with me
first of all um great theories great
voting everybody
um I'd like to say real a lot Jessica
you are very Rogue you're the Rogue
Queen and you like I said you are the
quantum to my mania so that's why
because you were you you'd be rogus all
day uh but now it's time for our Rogue
question you guys ready for this one
because the world was shocked shocked to
learn recently that there are plans for
an I Am Legend sequel more than 15 years
after that film's original release for
today's Rogue question what a long
forgotten film would you like to see
finally get its sequel you know what
mine's really dumb and it's only because
I was thinking about this movie recently
because I really like this movie
um have you seen Once Bitten the Jim
Carrey vampire movie that came out in
the 80s it's a very fun movie where he's
a virgin and he gets taken by
he's only virgin males and it's him and
his girlfriend's race to have sex before
today and the sequel if she survived and
she's been doing this for centuries get
another one keep
keep boys
gosh the movie it's funny
yeah I haven't seen that movie because I
only watch movies I can relate to and uh
I'm sorry I can't relate to virgins
um
just kidding just kidding
never mind all right here we go oh what
do you guys what do you guys got uh okay
I want to see a sequel to the 90s
rom-com bedazzled starring Elizabeth
Hurley and Brendan Fraser Brendan Fraser
sells his soul to the devil who is
Elizabeth Hurley and gets himself into
Shenanigans we're we're in the middle of
the Brendan science baby Brendan Fraser
is coming back and I think that this
would be a perfect sequel I want to see
it I want to see him sell his soul to
Satan again
everyone loves a good Brendan Frazier
I don't care I don't care what do you do
he can play I was gonna say he could
play Indiana Jones and I was like I
really like Harrison Ford as Indiana
Jones
[Applause]
okay okay hold on hold on Whitney how
about this how about this how about this
it's a sequel to bedazzle but it's
actually following Brendan Fraser
in real life and that's how he's getting
his Renaissance he sells the soldier
he's no longer yeah
[Music]
the devil still looks like Elizabeth
thoroughly because the devil saw the
movie and was like oh yes why not oh
okay yeah sure why not why wouldn't I
that was an option of course why
wouldn't I if that's an option if it's
an option object like Liz Hurley why not
you know I like all of these ideas so
um prior to the US going on air somebody
mentioned Rocketeer great choice great
choice but
um yeah great choice yeah but that but
that dislodged from my brain I would
like to see a sequel to uh the Phantom
Billy Zane starring The Phantom uh I
love that movie as a kid yeah
and also it lends itself because it's
supposed to be like a generational thing
like Billy Zane could be training the
next The Phantom
to save and the more I think that movie
was set in the 30s so you could set this
one in like uh what 60 70 something like
that that would be my choice let's do it
I'm gonna give you the Rogue question
trophy of the day because that is a very
original I I like that one the phantom
um so I'm gonna give you the Rogue
trophy um
stars and I don't have a star
subscription boo bring it to every
streaming platform stars is I think also
like um party down is coming back to
stars and I was like man am I gonna have
to get stars to watch party down I love
party down dude I can't believe that I
have to get stars to watch freaking
party down
party down in the Phantom right yes
subscribe to Stars we have party down
there and then like
an advertisement pitch all the a24
movies are like on Showtime or something
it's like I don't wanna
there's nothing else
those I watch
but yo if I
if I have this question I would probably
do uh Matilda too because I just want to
see what the ramifications of having
this little girl with powers are to the
world wasn't there Matilda too is there
a Matilda too
make things levitate right yeah but she
like reads books really good and then
she's like I could remove things from my
mind and my dad and then my dad's is
gonna sell bad cars and that's Matilda
and I'm chased by my principal anyway
um but anyways
I was thinking of the French the little
French girl that walks in twos she has a
little yellow Madeline yeah there is a
Madeline too you're right there is that
is it for this episode of Rogue Theory
thanks to our amazing guests Jessica
Clemens Whitney van leningham and DJ
Wooldridge support our Channel by
checking out all of our awesome merch
over at new roxasmirch.com head on over
to hellbentcomic.com was this is that
right yeah hellbentscomicbook.com yes
hellbedcomicbook.com to check out the
hell bent comic written by this amazing
man you can buy all three all three
volumes over at um that web site so
check that out um write down follow me
at masterton follow me rockstars on all
social platforms and be sure to
subscribe to our channel here on YouTube
and also subscribe to the Deep dive
which is our amazing new channel as well
see you guys next time we love you guys
so much be safe and bye
foreign
[Music]